[Music]
hey what's up everybody this is mike is
automotive welcome to my channel
dave robert shalom economically
automotive so today we have a 2018 honda
accord that we're going to do ah his
last and i'm also not cord
the honda dos militia
and then we're gonna choose type three
okay
if you're adding a key you can just do
it at type two
but if your block is lost you will need
to go to type three si no masters
so right now it's telling us to take all
the smokies out of the car
so i'm going to go ahead open the car
put the keys on top of the roof
double click start button whether it can
be switched on so right now it's asking
us if the ignition could be switched on
foreign
so it needs to be an accessory mode
and it doesn't let us so we're going to
go ahead and press snow on the auto pro
pad
so
okay
no cannot be switched on press and hold
the start button and press ok
so here's the part that's really tricky
you got to hold the button and at the
same time that you're holding the button
and press ok
and you can let it go okay
so as you guys can see the car is an
accessory mode we're able to turn on a
car come on
so it's asking us if the ignition is
switched on yes it is we're going to
press yes yes
it's telling us how many kids want to
put in the system we're going to put one
unai
it's telling us to turn off the car
just press it once to turn it off
now it's telling us to turn on the car
press it twice so we can turn it on to
accessory mode
excuse me we're going to press yes
because it's extinguished it's telling
us to turn it back on
now it's telling us to turn on the
ignition twice to turn it on
now it's telling us to turn off the
ignition again
and it's going to tell us to turn it
back back on one more time so twice to
turn it on
those buses
okay
as you guys can see the accessory mode
is on program success
you guys we have successfully programmed
our key we're going to go ahead try it
out turn on the vehicle see if it works
all right well thank you guys for
sticking here to the end
let me show you guys my initial
collection a lot of you guys always
mentioned hey um what are the best
niches to start off with well my answer
to you is all of them
todos
same thing with the keys
at least one of each you guys i always
have one of each
every kiss that i can think of okay
you can have at least one one of each
okay
and that's just uh hints for and tips
for all of you guys
okay starting off this business i need
to have
one i also have uh my extras remote so
they keep in stock
okay i keep one of each on display
if they like it i go to the back and i
um
take it off from there but yeah these
are all my keys okay so my inventory
okay well more than
i would like to say about um
three thousand dollars of inventory
right here or more
okay
let's go back to my leashes
so i have a gm39 h266 toy 4380
hu92 h258 b11
okay
and that's for um chrysler the black one
2043 okay it's toyota reverse
for some chevy
han 58 which is honda double sided i
have the hon six six the high security
one
the nissan 14 hu101 and f038 for the
ford high security okay and regular
go ahead you guys take notes
all right you guys for mechanical keys
and keys with chips
okay
that i keep at least keep four of them
okay with chips the generic keys
okay i have a lot of mechanical keys
metal keys
okay before i cut one of these
um
as for uh as for generic chips as well i
keep uh
i try to keep a few around
and i also have super chips
super chip
okay so these are my uh generic right
here and these are my super chip ae 13
4c 128
8a meg almost 13.
okay
my mfk keys right here you guys okay
these are all my mfk keys
you can make your own keys i have um
this thing you buy the key heads
separately the plastic pieces and you
put them together
and this comes in handy
okay so all you guys are starting
i do recommend the xp
dolphin
okay level of five let's pick a level
five
and of course you need a double sided
key cutter basic one so i do recommend
this one okay the xc 009 condor
it's good to have both
all right you guys are for programmers
i have the auto pro pad the auto the
x100 pad three
tango a lot of pro pad and laptop
sa
so these are my most my programmers that
i have the im608 pro the one that i use
the most is the auto pro pad is
one's more for asian vehicles domestic
vehicles
nissan ford toyota
honda okay more asian domestic efforts
domestic honda for nissan toyota
chevy
this one's more for um
for high-end luxury vehicles like
mercedes-benz european vehicles bmws
okay volkswagen audi
so i really wouldn't use this one you
know this also i wouldn't really take it
out to program a honda toyota or any
simple car like that
okay
i would use this one for a nissan toyota
or honda okay any asian simple vehicle
with these auto pro pad
or the or the pad 3.
okay
for more european complicated vehicles
on helping my im 608 pro
all right you guys well thank you guys
for watching now before you subscribe
join our membership until next time you
guys
like
um
you